[Music]
hello
oh no no no no
[Music]
we're here to investigate the death of a
nun September 17 witnessed the darkest
chapter the divide in the country
universe raided our
we need to pray no and whatever happens
whatever you may see or hear keep your
eyes forward and don't stop brain
[Music]
the nun read are experienced in hi max
September 7th
[Music]
George's
all those periods respire
[Music]
[Music]
one of the things that occurred to all
of us early on is they'd have a
superhero universe why can't we do that
in the horror at well when we were
making the first conjuring it became
very apparent to us that there could be
a bigger universe so many other great
stories that would be awesome to look
into there is this established timeline
how they all pieced together in
Annabelle creation we find out about how
origin
every time that doll appears on screen
people react people just love her the
country movies have got such strong
characters in them with Lorraine and Ed
Warren when we made conjuring 2 people
really loved the non character with the
nun we're going right back to where it
all began it's the origins of the
demonic entity that will be haunting the
Warrens
encountering - I can create something
that builds in that country an universe
that is also fresh and unexpected the
skills are different than anything
you've seen in the other conjuring
universe movie it's a completely
different environment as a fan we want
to see all the different stories
[Laughter]
I had a series of visions when I was
younger and after each one ended the
same thought would be stuck in my head
what you see I saw none
or do my visions reach the church and I
was asked to accompany a priest to an
abbey in Romania the Abbey has a long
history
[Music]
what should a hotel
Cara has here
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]